meantime families speaking out after
ccsd decided to restructure its
community engagement office this is
actually impacting family and community
engagement services or faces which
connects families with a variety of
resources and also classes kate houston
on this story has more on the impact it
will have on families
i'm really upset about it my my youngest
just turned three and she has been going
with me to the faces center since she
was two weeks old stephanie johnson has
attended faces for nearly five years
saying it's a huge part of how she
raises her kids there are so many
different things that face has addressed
that isn't quite available in the
community if you don't qualify for it
perfectly faces offers a variety of
bilingual courses valeria gur taught
some saying they were essential for
low-income families you're able to get
experts from all over the community to
bring and give classes to these parents
in a release ccsd says the new family
engagement department will provide
increased digital resources and home
visits we saw the family's struggle
using
a virtual system and now we're saying
that this is a solution i don't know i
don't understand it makes absolutely no
sense in an email to families face's
staff says this was unexpected for
everyone involved as parents like ccsd
didn't even think we needed deserved two
weeks notice that these programs were
going to be going away gur thinks this
will leave many families in the dark and
negatively impact kids schooling if you
want to really reimagine the program
offer both offer in person and offer
online and offer more kate houston live
local now
we did reach out to the school district
over email and on the phone to get more
clarification on what is happening to
these programs and these jobs at this
time as of airtime have not heard back